uh and then we have sentience oh the the
the amazing sentients the amazing
sentients 50 super chat
women have no idea when they ask uh for
men to be open and vulnerable as women
lead they will mold their men into
something they aboar
when you change when you change for her
she will leave you saying that you're
not the man she fell for around
zentian speaking facts
big facts sentience you know is that all
the super chats
um
we're gonna we're gonna talk about that
because that was like very interesting
do women change men
into the men they don't want and then
leave them
you have to answer this one first i
haven't seen that to be the k that's an
interesting point i think okay so i mean
i personally haven't seen that to be the
case but that's i think that's an
interesting point
so i'll say this right
in my experience it's been a little bit
older
a lot of the time women say they want
something but they don't actually want
it right okay they say they want
something so they say they want a man
who is a leader and he's a boss and he's
a worker and it's hard graft and
that man
is not going to be around a lot
because he's got work to do because he's
trying to
take care of the family the household
etc etc
if as a woman you now complain at the
fact that you don't see your man enough
he's going to be thinking
hang on a minute this is the man that
you wanted isn't it you wanted a man to
be provider
for the household now you're talking
about time and then
this actually happened to me
and then
you say okay cool
i'll work less hours
yeah
cool but the two holidays a year that
we'll take in
you ain't gonna be getting that
and you know certain things you're gonna
have to cut back on and then you cut
your hours
and then
it's like uh yeah i want to go on
holiday oh really you want to go on
holiday now when i'm not doing as many
hours as i was doing before
because you wanted me to spend with you
more time and now all of a sudden i'm
spending more time right now you want
the things that
as a man listening to a woman like
sentience was saying sometimes they're
like i heard
and that's what i've said as
misogynistic as it may sound
yeah
men should not listen to women
so they were you think they set you up
for failure i think women will set a man
up for failure and and the reason why i
say that is because women generally tend
to think with their emotions more than
so than logic and emotions can change in
a day to day that's what a balance
becomes it comes back to my original
point i was talking about in the very
beginning where i said i think well a
lot of times
if if
i was talking about social media and how
there was that difference between i want
an independent man versus a um
um i want to be an independent woman
versus a um traditional housewife i
think that a lot of women
it would depend on the days like there
were some days there wouldn't be city
girls hot girls just like did it they're
cool the other days where i'm like
actually i want to live a soft life this
that i thought i agree with you i think
a lot of women just don't know what it
is they want or they think they know
what they want but they don't realize
the consequences that come what do you
think what do you think the reason is
that though do you think it's like
exposure of social media
i think women are emotionally led
i mean they're led by their emotions and
emotions changing in in the drop of a
hat yeah i think a woman can be coming
up to her period and think something on
the during that week yeah and then after
the period she's like oh you know yeah i
don't really wanna and the thing is if
is if as a man you say that you're a
misogynist right if you but the thing is
no it's because we understand logically
what is going on as a man i've been in a
related i was my past relationship was
for 10 years i was in a 10-year
relationship
right
and so
i saw being around a woman
for that period of time
i saw her change
on those days
yeah i'm saying like i saw the change
personally and men that have been around
women and not only with that a little
bit of a personal life i grew up in a
household with four women yeah
so seeing them there were times i'll be
like i'm locking myself in my room my
sister's gonna do their thing because i
know because you know when women get in
the same vicinity
they start sinking right their peers
start sinking and i'm like you know what
it's that time and when i see my
sister's doing certain things i'm like
yo i'm gonna i'm gonna hit my room and
i'm not gonna do that so as men when
you're around women on a constant basis
you get to see the changes that happen
within women right and so seeing that
growing up and then getting into a
relationship for so long
i can actually confidently say yeah
when you're at that time
you ain't the same person in fact
you're not and the thing is you might
not want to hear that on this show there
was a lady called eileen that i had a
conversation with right and we were
talking about
and she was saying yeah women are
different on their period even pearl was
saying yeah i mean myself was saying
that we are different on our period
right right and
but if as a man you say that
they don't want to hear that they want
to hear that because you're a man in
fact that's why but the thing is the
reason why we're saying that is because
we can see
that you're different around this time
we're not saying it's a good thing it's
not saying it's a bad thing we're just
saying you know what
you're acting different right now is it
that time yeah but if you say that
it's trouble i i think i think like like
we were saying earlier it just comes
down to balance i think you should be
able to recognize if you can recognize
those moments you should be able to
recognize when to listen to her or not
because i don't think it's fair to just
say don't listen to women don't um like
don't discard like just disregard her
needs and just
ignore what she has to say because there
may be times where a woman is genuinely
trying to communicate something that she
wants from a person and that shouldn't
be disregarded so i think there is
definitely that balance that okay yeah
if you can see that sometimes you just
this is you i know i know you and i know
that this isn't what you want as opposed
to actually this is something i
genuinely want now would be a good time
for you to listen to me i don't want to
disregard your point i think it's very
valid in its own right i just going back
to sarah's question
should men take advice from women or if
women oh yeah opinions like
my experience is that women are not
equipped because they don't know the
male experience to give advice to men so
men should necess really just go to
other men
right within their peer group to ask for
advice on how to deal with their
relationship problems and issues that
they have because those men are equipped
um and have their experience amongst a
group of them to be able to give the
right solution so i was
i was in a tenured relationship you're
you're basically married yeah right in a
ten-year relationship right so within
that time
what i learned within because i i'm
around men that have been in like quite
long-term relationships um i know it's
you know it's like a myth nowadays yeah
but i was in with men that are in quite
long-term relationships so
one of the things i found is that when
it came to finances
right
women generally tend to spend more than
men right
they generally have impulse buying
right
and if i'm going to
a woman for financial advice
it's a wrong thing to do because most
consumer debt is actually by women women
are the ones that are most women know
how to buy women are having amazon prime
deliveries to their house nearly every
week right for something new and a lot
of the time they aren't even wearing
this they're returning yeah they're
returning it i was sitting in their
closet they ain't doing something so i'm
saying within a marriage because um
like i think men when it comes to
marriage need to kind of understand
what it is
to be within a marriage with a woman who
is actually a woman who goes through all
of the cycles that women go through and
that's why i think we lack
we don't know that so i would be i'll be
honest right now a lot of men don't know
that right now do you think you're
marriage material me not right now right
not right now i'm still i'm 20 year old
i'm 20 i'm 21 years old young i got a
lot to learn
i want to be i want to be husband
material
but um i know i got a lot to learn
financially mentally and logically where
are you going to get that where am i
going to get that i'm going to get it
from my experiences within um
within
my career and my experience with women
you know i mean
um because i like i think the only way
to learn is just being in it be in it
i feel like you need to
it's not even is it is it is it my
saying to say you have to kiss a few
frogs to learn
no because experience you can expect you
have to gain experience you have to gain
what you want and what you actually want
as a man or a woman but um that's what i
think i'm gonna gain gain that gain now
do you think you're marriage material
not currently no not at all i'd like
like ashley said i think i agree with
this point i would want to be um but i
don't think i fully am right now and i
think i'm still exploring my wants and
needs as well
and that comes through experience
and yeah